Following Betty White's death on December 31,
2021, Bob Saget penned a heartfelt tribute to
the comedy icon. Ten days later, the comedy
world is mourning the loss of Saget himself.
For decades, Saget was known for his edgy
stand-up comedy, his long-running hosting
stint on America's Funniest Home Videos, and
memorable roles as Danny Tanner on Full House
and as the narrator on How I Met Your Mother.
Saget was actively working as an entertainer
up until the time of his death.
Before he unexpectedly passed,
he was set to continue his nationwide
stand-up tour into the spring of 2022.
Now, the world is in shock at the sudden loss of
the beloved performer. The unexpected death lands
even harder, since it seems like Saget had begun
to hit his stride on his latest comedy tour, and
appeared to be gearing up for a new phase of his
career with a renewed focus on live performance.
After performing what would ultimately
be his final show, Saget tweeted:
"Loved tonight’s show
PV_ConcertHall in Jacksonville.
Appreciative audience. Thanks again
to RealTimWilkins for opening.
I had no idea I did a 2 hr set tonight.
I’m happily addicted again to this s—."
Condolences and remembrances have been pouring
in from fans and fellow Hollywood stars in the
wake of this tragedy, a mere 10 days after Saget
himself mourned the loss of another comedy giant:
Betty White, who died a few
weeks shy of her 100th birthday.
"I'm an old lady to the rest of the
world but to me I'm just a girl."
In the days following White's death,
Saget shared his memories of White on
his Instagram. In the tribute, the famously
blue comedian recalled a story where he and
White were on a private jet drinking Bloody
Marys and laughing together. He wrote,
"I looked into her eyes and faux romantically
said, 'How 'bout it, Betty, you and me in the
bathroom? Mile High Club?' She answered me before
I had a chance to finish the invite — 'Of course,
Bob, you go in there first and I'll
meet you as soon as I finish my drink.'"
Saget went on to jokingly add that Betty continued
sipping her drink while he waited in the bathroom,
for what he claimed was over two hours. Assuming
that his joke might be taken totally out
of context, the actor went on to clarify,
"That would be the joke on a joke part,
in case you take things literally."
Beyond recollecting this humorous encounter,
Saget more seriously mused on White's
view of the afterlife. He continued,
"She always said the love of her life was her
husband, Allen Ludden, who she lost in 1981.
Well, if things work out by Betty's
design [...] they are reunited.
I don't know what happens when we
die, but if Betty says you get to
be with the love of your life, then
I happily defer to Betty on this."
No one could have known the world
would lose Saget just a few days later,
and it's especially emotional to read these
words now. Fans have already taken to the
Instagram post's comments section to express
their grief over the surprising loss of Saget.
Even before Saget's death, fans were showing up
in droves for his Instagram post honoring Betty
White. Now that his poignant words have accrued
additional weight in the wake of his passing,
that fan response has become even more
overwhelming. Many commenters picked up on
White's hopeful impression of the afterlife
and ran with it, wishing Saget well in his
reunion with one of his comedy idols. One
commenter with the handle youngeds wrote:
"Together now drinking bloody Mary's
in heaven may you both Rest In Peace."
Another commenter that goes by tufftopic added:
"Wow! You two are now angels
and will meet again! Rip Bob!."
Despite coming from different generations,
Saget and White clearly touched many of the
same lives and shared many fans as
a result. The comments that didn't
specifically focus on the heavenly
reunion between the two blue comics,
simply used the space to honor Saget. A user
with the handle jeimbinder wrote in the comments:
"gonna miss you man. You
brought so many smiles. Rip."
The comedy world is reeling from the loss
of two titans in such close proximity,
but if Betty White was right — and, honestly,
when wasn't she? — they just might be cracking
each other up on another plane of existence.